la cuestión Palestina no está resuelta y
en medio las víctimas como él sale
expulsada por Israel junto a sus hijos
soy una defensora de los Derechos
Humanos pero sobre todo en esta historia
soy la mujer de salah cuando la gente
habla de ello habla de un expediente de
un caso o de alguien que ilustra un
símbolo tal vez pero estoy hablando de
mi marido al que he hecho de menos a
diario
es un abogado Franco palestino lleva
nueve meses encarcelado y siete años
separado de su familia Le acusan de ser
miembro del frente popular para la
liberación de Palestina
nos golpearon en nuestra felicidad y nos
pusieron delante de una elección que
nadie debería tener que hacer en su vida
que es tienes que elegir entre tu patria
y tu mujer y tu hijo
[Música]
está en prisión preventiva en febrero
tiene una audiencia que podría llevarle
a una deportación su detención sin
cargos ni juicio ha sido denunciada por
organizaciones como acciones cristianas
para La abolición de la tortura que el
primero de diciembre le entregan un
premio de Derechos Humanos a él sale fog
en su nombre
el hecho de no saber su fecha de
liberación es también una tortura
psicológica pero esta tortura se aplica
a todos sus familiares que también
esperan y se preguntan cuándo terminará
este trato cruel
la ONU celebra cada 29 de noviembre el
día de solidaridad con el pueblo
palestino después de que en 1947 la
asamblea general resolviese la
resolución de la partición donde se
establece la creación de un estado judío
y otro árabe hasta el momento solo
existe Israel